tell us a little bit about yourself you
seem like a nice cool chap what uh what
are you up to what tell us about your
life who are you so I'm a I'm a
developer so I work for I just finished
my master thesis and like software
engineering and then now I work as a
developer but I also make a ton of music
on this side which you can maybe tell
from like
the 50 000 instruments yes around in my
room I see that yeah so you're a
musician yeah I make Norwegian pop uh
like funk music really wait do you
prefer do you have a group yeah we have
a group called The Ada which is I like
the kind of a joke-ish like we make good
music but like the the essence of the
music is kind of almost like like Lonely
Island Vibes if you know what I mean
right you're it's kind of uh satirical
uh silly yeah kind of but we do have
Baggers though I should yeah check us
out okay like get your name out there
what's it called Eda yeah what is that
mean so that actually it actually
originated as a joke because that in our
dialect if I like were to talk to
Norwegian and I would say Ada that would
mean that would be translated to is it
so our joke was like if that's the name
every song kindly is a question oh
because I see is it is it really so
party in here right
just well that's a good question we came
up with that joke before we started
making music
to be honest with you most parties I
attend that's one of my first questions
is is it a party in here oh okay is it
uh so yeah
so I have a question for you which is
tell us about your group you have this
group it's two of you
um what kind of music do you do is it is
it high energy are you guys kind of like
quietly like software developers just
playing your mooc synthesizers what tell
us about your performances I will be
honest though I would love to make that
type of music too but no that that's
more like way more upbeat party music we
play a lot of like our dialects being
from like Bergen and stuff because we do
sound like a bunch of like if you have
the Norwegian stereotype of how we sound
like the horror Yar Yar that's how we
talk regularly
so we like we played a lot of that I'm
like the energetic one well he's the
that pretty one I guess what well you're
pretty good looking yeah I mean he must
be a real stunner yeah I want to see you
guys jarla I I was I've got a thing for
you already you're you're I think you're
a dreamy fella I can't imagine how good
looking what's the other guy's name
Christian uh way easier to pronounce
yeah yeah I see why he gets all the
attention because you can say his name
that's why I'm trying to go for Charlie
Conan you see the goddamn problem here
all right let's watch the language this
is a children's podcast
um oh crap sorry so basically this is
are you a Norwegian rap Duo is that fair
to say yeah that's perfect can you give
me a sampling of Norwegian rap just so I
can hear it can you wrap a Norwegian for
me
uh
anything it doesn't have to make sense
because we won't understand it okay
check it um check it foreign
foreign
I would be honored to I want to be a hit
on the Norwegian pop charts is that a
possibility that is an above zero
percent possibility
over one percent but it's like
definitely
[Music]
mid zeros listen Okay zero
you heard him beatboxing too right it's
it's tragic when he tries to do anything
cool like I think Zuma some kind of like
safety feature because it all got muted
out on the way over here luckily so I
was spared yeah Zoom does have a
function in there yeah a special program
that yeah
idiot extreme white boy filter yeah so
you're half what do you dress like okay
I'm trying to visual I've got a sense of
what you sound like how are you dressed
when you're performing in uh Etta uh
well so we we kind of have like a color
scheme going well I'm like yellow
because I guess it's an energetic color
and he he's purple so I often have like
either like completely like one of those
colors or like you know wear something
of that color but I I like a lot of
lights uh like loose jackets like a lot
of loose clothes yeah yeah he's more
like straight yeah baggy exactly so but
I have I want to like totally get the um
like hazmat suits from Breaking Bad I
basically just wear that for the
performing live sure yeah and while
you're at it you might as well make some
meth yeah uh while you're out there yeah
I mean why waste the time I mean it's
not a profitable business column so you
know we gotta make we got to make some
money wasn't a profitable business and I
was about to correct you
Sona and gorley have done quite well